with more on the battle over the border
the so-called big government shutdown
which is never really a shutdown South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham is with
us senator it makes my blood boil
because this has happened time and again
we have people that didn't respect our
laws or our sovereignty come to America
commit more crimes they are in custody
and then they are literally like a state
like California they are protected from
the laws of the land and they commit
horrific fines me now is California are
they going to pay the funeral costs are
they gonna pay the college tuition how
do they explain to this five month old
little boy that daddy's never coming
back again well these policies that make
it more likely that terrorists drug
dealers and criminals can come to
America and have safe haven so you said
before I think Steve is a great guy he
said Democrats are not for border
security yeah they are except when
Trump's president I've seen them in
action they have all voted for twenty
five forty two billion dollars you name
the number for border security they
won't give a dime to this president
because they want him to fail walzwerk
Trump said let's make a deal Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer said go to hell
we'll see what happens you offered a
compromise now Democrats also say they
care about the dollar kids
what is your compromise compromise is
give president the five billion dollars
we need for wall slash border security
as a down payment to secure in the
border the daka population about 700,000
give them work permits through your work
permit so they don't have to worry about
getting deported any time soon the TPS
people who came here years ago from
war-torn areas hurricanes and floods we
know their legal status no pathway to
citizenship in call it a day is called
compromise the president said let's make
a deal
the press the Democratic response is
basically go to hell they're going to
send a bill from the house to the Senate
that has no money for the wall
it's not gonna see the light of day
mitch mcconnell's never gonna bring the
bill on to the floor of the Senate that
doesn't have money for the wall we need
the wall they've all voted yes and the
only we're ever going to get the wall is
to fight for it this is a battle to me
worth having and I know it's
inconvenient by the way I support us all
those furloughed employees I don't want
them caught in a political crossfire
they deserve their back pay it's it's
through no fault of their own that they
are not viewed as essential services but
will the president the president have
other options for the wall for example
why is this not viewed he's the
commander in chief he's in charge of
national security of this country why
couldn't defense department funds be
used to secure our border to stop the
drug trafficking human trafficking and
even the criminal gangs in the 3,700
terrorists that Steve Scalise mentioned
that were caught trying to cross our
border why is that not a national
security Defense Department issue you
can move some money around but he'll get
sued there'll be lawsuits in California
to stop any effort to have other
agencies fund the border but there's
some money you could use for sure but
why should this president have to play
that game
why should Donald Trump have to do that
when Democratic presidents and
Republican presidents in the past were
able to get money to secure the border
on Democrats last question shouldn't
have to do that
I agree fight I support on another stage
105 oh we're not giving up do we get the
money if this takes 150 days I think the
Republican Party needs to stand united
with the president I don't I have
confidence in you I don't know if
confidence in some of your colleagues
but saving lives stopping drug
trafficking and human trafficking is
worth the fight will the president hold
the line we'll have the Republican
support he needs to hold the line well
let me tell you how our government works
any bill passed from the house has to
come to the Senate desk get 60 votes
important to be signed in the law the
president has to sign it he's not going
to sign a bill that doesn't have money
for the wall
I tell you exactly how this is going to
end the president is going
challenged the democrats to compromise
and if they continue to say no they're
going to pay a price with American
people most Americans want to do two
things they want to secure our border
and they want to be reasonable to the
people like the daca population if he
gives in now that's the end of 2019 in
terms of him being an effective
president that's probably the end of his
presidency Donald Trump has made a
promise to the American people he's
going to secure our border every
Democrat in the past three with a border
funding he now they're changing their
mind it's too important too many lives
at stake
too much danger to the country senator
good to see if that's the end of us if
we give on on this issues Republicans
I'll get your Mitt Romney they're
hustling so slippery we help them grow a
spine will ya anyway thanks for being
with us happy days here at man